back in early march at the start of the
russian invasion of ukraine i did a
story called could putin be terminally
ill
and the story it garnered great interest
about a quarter of a million views on
youtube another similar number on
facebook and as i said at the time it
was a speculative story we're trying to
make sense of an invasion that appears
to make no sense vladimir putin's face
was pudgy could he be on steroids for
some medical condition could it be a
reason for rambling and aggression and
many of you agreed yeah i mean it
maybe it is but it remained quite
speculative there is now much more
pressing speculation about putin's
illness after a new video of vladimir
putin has been released
we have this video which we're putting
up on the screen this was a meeting that
putin had with his defense minister
sergey shoigu and in the video putin is
visibly gripping the table in front of
him apparently for support
um he looks pale
he looks bloated even more bloated than
he previously looked and he grips the
table for basically the entire 12-minute
video that was released by the kremlin
and the idea is that he's gripping it to
avoid some kind of tremor or shaking
from being visible but if you he's doing
this with his right hand if you look at
his left hand in the video
it is very shaky and moving around in
what some are describing as a kind of
unusual way it doesn't seem deliberate
putin's kind of hunched back on the seat
back and he's regularly tapping his toes
in a way which it might just be a tick
it could be indicative of something
parkinsonian it could be a side effect
from a medication professor eric busey
who's a body language expert from texas
tech university said the face looks
clearly bloated and that there's a
general unhealthy appearance
and meanwhile the unconfirmed rumors
about putin being in treatment for
cancer continued to be published by
various media outlets they are not
confirmed but it's hard to argue at this
point that putin seems healthy now the
kremlin has denied allegations that
putin's health is a problem
but the speculation has included
prostate cancer
thyroid cancer parkinson's or something
parkinsonian
tardive dyskinesia is usually a side
effect of medication
uh wouldn't tell us the underlying
situation but it's something else that's
being mentioned now why does this matter
well it matters because circumstantially
this relates to the invasion of ukraine
in that if putin were very ill if putin
were terminally ill
it almost would be more sensible that he
might be trying to go out in a blaze of
erratic aggression meant to reconstitute
the soviet union and being seen as a
martyr for mother russia and as crazy as
that sounds
it makes more sense than just like
he decided to invade ukraine i mean it
makes no sense in in in a in thinking in
a logical way
now this is one of those you know it's a
low probability but high risk event
if this is really what's going on if
this is an erratic unhinged putin on his
last leg as far as his life goes not his
political life and he thinks hey i'm
going to die soon
what's the downside to using nukes
if that's the state of mind that he's in
and again this is speculative
but it is fueling the conversation again
about our is anybody thinking of an
assassination attempt and as i've said
before
when we talk about
intelligence for high-level western
countries
they are
supposed to present all options and so
without saying anybody's thinking of
assassinating putin
it is without a doubt
that when intelligence had sit down with
heads of state
they give every option and so it is
almost a certainty that could it even be
done
when it comes to assassinating putin has
been discussed when we say all options
are presented they present all options
so newfound questions about vladimir
putin's health he doesn't look good will
we ever really know the truth
i have absolutely no idea
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts
my subscription to aura gives me peace
of mind uh protects my devices it
protects all of my different accounts
and i can monitor everything in one
place on the app if i get attacked aura
actually takes action to prevent and
resolve the issues in real time and aura
is letting my audience try it completely
free for 14 days go to aura.com
pacman the link is down below